I have a ton of non-trump news to
discuss with you today and in a moment
we're gonna be focusing in on Arizona
and the Senate race that's going on in
Arizona but before I do that I want to
talk about the Senate more broadly a
little bit I don't know with everything
that's going on how many people in my
audience are following what's going on
with the Senate for November of 2020 but
it is increasingly clear that if we all
come together if we do the hard work if
we do the phone banking if we get out
there and vote there is a realistic shot
that Republicans could lose control of
the Senate in November now a year ago
when we were talking about this I was
mostly saying it's like a five percent
chance I mean Democrats could take the
Senate but really we're probably going
to have to wait until 2022 to see
Republicans lose control of the Senate
and then six months ago things have
shifted a little bit I did a segment
pointing out it's in play it's probably
still like a 20 percent shot at taking
the Senate for Democrats
there is now an increasingly realistic
scenario where Democrats snatched
control of the Senate from Republicans
in November now to refresh the numbers
right now the balance of power is 53 to
47 in favor of Republicans that is the
47 is 45 Democrats and then two
independents Bernie Sanders and angus
King that's how you get to 47 if the
Senate is tied 50/50 the vice president
gets to cast the tie-breaking vote so
right now if Democrats want control they
need a net gain of four seats or three
seats plus the presidency because then
Joe Biden's vice president becomes the
tiebreaker in a 50/50 Senate now
Democrats are going to lose Alabama this
is just a reality Alabama there's this
Senate seat that used to be Jeff
Sessions seat Republican jeff sessions
became Trump's beleaguered Attorney
General Doug Jones defeated serial
accused sex assault or Roy Moore but
that is an anomaly an anomaly depending
on how you like to pronounce it and Jeff
Sessions is running for that seat again
and he's almost certain to win he's
winning by a ton so in practice losing
that one
this means Demick
to need five wins against Republicans or
4 wins plus the presidency and it is not
a crazy scenario at this point to
imagine that that might happen it would
be a major turn of events from what we
would have been looking at six months
ago in great part you would blame Trump
you could blame the virus but
Republicans have a very difficult path
now to defending control of the Senate
compared to 6 or 12 months ago you've
got a hundred senators they served
six-year terms that means every two
years a third of the Senate is up for
re-election right now we have 33 races
plus two special elections Arizona and
Georgia and of those 35 Republicans have
to defend 23 whereas Democrats are only
defending 12 in other words Republicans
have 23 seats they could lose
whereas Democrats have only 12 seats
that they could lose now I've already
mentioned Alabama and Democrats almost
certainly Democrats are going to lose
that Alabama Senate seat let's look at
the best shots for Democrats to take
seats from Republicans first of all
you've got Colorado where John
Hickenlooper the Democrat is leading the
incumbent Republican Cory Gardner by 13
that will very likely flip in Arizona
Mark Kelly is leading martha mcsalley
the incumbent Republican by an average
of nine now in one recent poll it's 13
and we'll talk about that a little later
in Maine you have Sarah Gideon the
Democratic challenger to longtime
Republican senator Susan Collins ahead
by about two and a half and then in
North Carolina it's very close Cal
Cunningham the Democratic challenger
ahead of incumbent Republican senator
Tom Tillis by one I mean that that's
like a tie it's the margin of error then
you've got some longer shots for
Democrats in terms of the longer shots
in Montana Steve Bullock has a very good
recent poll against the incumbent
Republican Steve Daines
I'm still calling it a long shot because
it is just one poll and it is Montana
but Montana doesn't look bad for
Democrats then you've got Georgia Kansas
and Iowa which are as we're calling them
those are long shots for Democrats but
they are not completely in
so the news is the Senate is very much
in play it's very much worth fighting
for this has been a big reversal over
the last six and particularly if you
look at what the polling was twelve
months ago but voters need to vote
otherwise this is nothing this is going
to be another opportunity lost if people
don't get out and vote I don't want to
see that happen now let's focus in on
one Senate race and I'll use it to look
more broadly at the signal that the
Senate races could send about the
presidential race let's dig into Arizona
right now our sponsor Nord VPN is giving
you 70% off a three-year plan which is
just a little over three bucks a month
and you will get an extra month three
when you go to Nordby pn comm slash
david pakman or just go to their website
and use the coupon code david pakman by
this point in time if you're not using a
VPN when you're on the Internet
you are putting yourself at a huge
disadvantage Nord VPN keeps your IP
address hidden when you're browsing
online keeps your personal data safe
from hackers prevents websites from
following you around the internet and
you can even use it on your phone there
are many different VPN options out there
but Nord VPN is the one I trust because
they don't log your internet history
they use military-grade encryption and
they encrypt your data twice to double
the anonymity Nord VPN is giving you 70%
off a three-year plan that's just over
three bucks a month plus an extra month
free when you go to north VPN dot-com
slash David Pakman I've put a link right
underneath the video or just go to their
website and use the coupon code david
pakman